passt aber auf die straße auto bild
autor oder servus s kids und herzlich
willkommen mit einem kleinen block aus
berlin
heute gehe ich ein bisschen shoppen und
ich nehme ich mit mit dabei ist leon und
wir probieren heute mal was aus das
mache ich heute zum ersten mal nicht
loks direkt für euch und zwar habe ich
mir hier so eine app heruntergeladen
damit kann man sich fahrzeuge mieten um
die sind jetzt gerade hier
da steht das auto das habe ich schon
reserviert man sieht da vorne schon es
ist ein scheiß cargo leider keinen der
auf 80 also ich muß für den kassier
tatsächlich bezahlen partner wir fahren
jetzt zum kadewe so leute ich hab das
jetzt hier mit dem handy freigeschaltet
hat es nicht funktioniert beim zweiten
versuch aber doch und jetzt ist die
offene art car to go bezahlt mir den
käse doch
ok auto abgestellt leute ich sage euch
obwohl es ein smart war obwohl es nicht
mein eigenes auto war es ist die
absolute hölle am kudamm auto zu fahren
also wirklich ein sehr schönes maarten
parkplatz zu finden dazu kommt auch noch
dass ich jetzt nicht der beste einpacker
bin aber hey wir haben jetzt geschafft
das auto stehen lassen zum pc meine
sachen und dann weiter zum kadewe die
übrigens praktischerweise direkt
nebeneinander sind ein stück weiter oben
zweiter versuch
okay aber nicht fündig geworden jetzt
geht's in die 3
niveau
dann schauen sie fährt ein scheiß fährt
okay leute wir sind jetzt im sechsten
stock ohne flor
wir gucken mal dass wir was zu trinken
kriegen wenn wir heute nur zum frühstück
was getrunken es ist jetzt schon 18 uhr
so leute ein paar stiefel am netz
gefunden
wir sehen diese so aus jetzt haben noch
20 minuten bis der pc und das kadewe
schließen wir wollen mal zum verzehr
über und mütze schal und handschuhe
kaufen so schuh gekauft jetzt haben wir
noch 15 minuten zeit es ist viertel vor
acht uhr schließt das ganze so fündig
geworden mit schal handschuhe mütze und
nochmal schale in der hand macht jetzt
genau zu genau jetzt deswegen sagt man
bei allen notfalls kann man immer noch
umtauschen den ich mir zumindest weil
ich auch und ich mag geld dafür
auszugeben besuchen jetzt noch mal ein
auto mit dem wir nach hause fahren
können auf der straße auf die straße
auto
auch
kanzler wir haben jetzt gerade mal nach
einem auto ausschau gehalten ganz
gefunden
hier unten sind wir da oben steht das
auto weiß nicht wie weit das ist also
die etwa 700 meter wenn es mehr sind du
scheiße komme ich vorbei und mach dich
zum deb er war scheiße war richtig
scheiße übrigens nur vorteile hat
angeblich sind 700 meter großen
waldwirtschaft ausgetrickst
ich rede nicht mit der irlands statue
jeweils ab ist vorne
in diesem dunklen kästchen da steht
unser auto ich hoffe wir werden jetzt
nicht mehr ausgeraubten liegen gelassen
aber es kann sein
das hier ist unser auto
es ist so eine richtige verlassene gasse
man wartet einfach darauf dass
dumbledore gleich um die ecke kommen
alle lichter ausgehen bekommen bei
kaffee dort dreht sich durch stehen
heute das was von der heutigen tour